thank you everybody
and let me start
with a question
why do we become data scientists
is it money
is it image
or is it love
it's because we love working with data
and gaining insights
out of it
if i'm reading a room correctly
i would say
it's actually love
second questions
how do we become data scientists
and i know there are
100 different stories on how we became
data scientists or data people but most
stories are some
version of this
there's some analytical background you
get
interested in data
then you learn data science skills on
your own on a job
through a boot camp
and hopefully at that moment you really
discover well this is super cool i want
to continue working with data
you apply a job apply for a job and
around that time congratulations you are
a data scientist
and what happens next next
you enter the job you get very company
specific data you start
being involved in meetings and projects
and in that time it might happen
to start forgetting where that initial
spark or initial love
came from
or
even worse
you continue on your career and at some
point
you really have so many other tasks that
you really
really don't have the time to
remind yourself where is the spark
of love you had to work with data and
if this sounds like i'm talking about
personal experiences well
maybe
and
one way i've dealt with that is by
teaching the other why it the other way
is by working
on so-called personal data projects
which are self-describing
and the good thing about personal data
projects is that
there is data available so if you're
using a smartphone you are
recording personal data
all the time so we have data available
we care about the topic and the
on the data where we should it's about
us and our life
and if you gain insights
they are going to be relevant because
they're about your life
my first
experience with personal data projects
was around at the time when i was
starting as a data scientist and on this
talk i will talk about
three different projects
the first one
was in december 2016 and one fact that
you should know to understand the talk
is that in my family we take the
tradition of making advent's calendar
very very seriously
this means in november mid-november
you really get in this stressful phase
of what am i going to do to start on the
1st of december
and december 2016 i
had some ideas and what i also had was
lots of whatsapp data so my partner and
me at that time
were living in different cities so we
were
talking a lot through whatsapp so we
probably
got to know each other through whatsapp
and on the weekends
so i had 36 months of whatsapp data and
at that time i was
using the r toolkit for data analysis
and visualization
so i took all these 36 months analyzed
the data
and started to make plots and what i
constructed was a
big
a
two poster infographic
with lots of different
graphs from our
live in emoji annotated with things that
were happening
to the distribution of words in time of
course on word clouds the change in
languages we were using over time
because
we had german spanish and english going
on there in the relationship
[Music]
then i made a
arts and crafts project out of it i was
really cutting
christmas wrapping paper and making
little stickers out of it
and then in december she could open one
by one and discover
some insights
about
our relationship
and at that time i thought well if i
already made all this work i might as
well use this for something important
and
i decided to ask her to america with it
with the title and
she said yes
[Applause]
thanks fast forward
whatsapp data
has actually lost its value
i
i exported
i exported the data
last week again to see how our usage had
changed and
this is the time i made the advanced
calendar we were at that time already at
a low time at a all-time low but this
just kept decreasing but of course we
moved in together then the pandemic
happened we were all the time together
we didn't need what's up anymore we
moved to
signal telegram and uh
so the messages really decreased
and not only the messages the number of
messages
also the content so i made an analysis
of lexical richness
and at the beginning we were really
talking about like our life philosophy
the universe and everything and nowadays
really what's up is like how are you
great and please go to the supermarket
and buy these things yeah so
this is this is what what's up it's used
uh for now
um so for the second project it wasn't
whatsapp data anymore
but it was an advanced calendar so
four years later
again mid-november what shall i do for
the advanced calendar
we had been one year into the pandemic
and the one thing that was kept more or
less constant is that we were still
playing lots of board games so we have
this hobby of
playing board games and
we had
all plays so l games recorded in the
board game board game
stats app um at that time i had also
already changed to the python
environment
and um so from
all the boards wins we had what happened
the pandemic is what used to be this
very social thing where we would meet
with friends and play
uh became one of a one versus one
situation where we would just play lots
of rounds
one against the other so this
over 500 plays are really games one
against the other
and there's this very neat board game
stats app that
funny enough i'm not the one using yeah
so
um
but my my partner my wife uh locks every
play and this is very handy because
there's already a database this is
synced to the biggest database of board
games you choose your the the board game
how long you played who won the score
and this thing will will make some
graphs
out of it
and
the best thing about it it has an export
button
so
i stole the phone
exported the data and
made a new advanced calendar out of it
a more traditional one you know where
you have like little cards and there's
your like small cards
with graphs about our board game
behavior and i have some some examples
for you
we
really play
a lot like
this a lot where around 18 hours per
month
that's the slope of the fitted model
pretty steady at that time
don't ask me how it smell
we also don't play a lot we play
very different games so we are like
explorative players so we like to try
out many different games either by
borrowing games from from neighbors or
in a the big ebay
um buy and sell a board game
world
and
we also had
the top games played by iteration and
the ones of you that know something
about the topic you see a lot of legacy
games so games that you play and you
continue the story and you continue this
story
some games that are very um long on its
own so he we have transforming mars like
nine hours that's like four times
playing so that's not
so many times but very long games or
just games that we really really liked a
lot
now you if you know something about the
topic then you also know that these are
all competitive games we're not the
collaborative gamers
so most of the stats
um in the most interesting stats were
about
who has won what when
and you might see
that i have
many more
more games where i was leading but she
was winning in the more complex games
which is very annoying and
we were also tied in some and
my most painful card
is this graph of games i lost by one
point in the score really one point and
how long we played and you saw the first
one
where like over two hours for losing for
one point and you see the four longest
games i lost by this one point
so
you see it's it's fun yeah it it's it's
personal but it's it's fun and you
um
you actually learn something out of the
thing
in
august that year she had a birthday and
again i didn't know what to get her but
what i did have was this very clean
board game data and it was very easy to
actually plug that data
into a classification model to predict
actually the winner
and i put it in my newest favorite tool
streamlin
to gave her a website present so this is
a small
data app
that can't predict who will win a game
we can choose from board games we've
played
and then we can predict who will be the
winner
we get some probability
and this is based on the stats of the
game if we've played it
the time of time of the day and
day of the week because this also had
some impact
and
the properties of the game so
this there's a big database of
board games board game geek and they
have tags they have the game complexity
game type categories mechanics
and
with this information
i could also predict games we didn't we
hadn't played before
um
and
yeah it's just a coincidence i picked
examples where i would have had a high
probability of filming of course
so now every time we play we can ask
first and test test the model and test
how we're doing
yes so that was the second one
before i start about
talking about the third project
um which is about something with a kid
um so lots of things change in your life
when when you have a kid you have less
time to play board games for once but
also you start
wondering about decisions you're making
and for me one of big decisions were
like what am i doing with the data
sharing
so it's it's one thing if i want to
use some kind of app without reading the
whole terms of usage but it was another
feeling for me to share data about
another person here in my kid without
actually informing myself what was
happening with the data
so
there were many things i wanted to track
of course when the kid was born and i
saw these beautiful visualizations in
the net on sleeping patterns or
lack of sleeping patterns and feeding
times etc but i didn't want to use any
of those apps so
i wasn't actually tracking
anything
um that was until
he started talking
because at that time i thought like well
now this is interesting data so
he started saying his first words
growing up in a bilingual environment
and i've been working on the side for a
long time with a friend of mine who is a
linguistic researcher
working actually in a language
acquisition in bilingualism
so
i knew
this this was interesting data
um
so i started tracking really with a
spreadsheet
and i was writing
the word
and a timestamp
and the language the word was in
um
and i was distinguishing between spanish
german and neutral for all names or or
proper names or english words that just
happen to get infiltrated
and again i use the typical
data analysis and and plotting um tools
plus spacey to do a bit of nlp on the
words
and i did the
analysis last week so after being
recording for 17 months i finally took a
look at this
first thousand words
and what i saw first
confirmed my feeling that at the
beginning it was very easy to track the
words yeah it was like mama oh great
banana okay two months later
bal and like okay third word yeah but at
some point they were like so many new
words per day and
my
linguistic
friend explained that after between 50
and 100 words there is this so-called
vocabulary spurt that's when there's an
acceleration in the rate at which
children acquire new words and you see
this beautiful beautifully in the data
yeah this elbow of like the zoop it
starts increasing radically
and um what i thought it would be the
most interesting content there
were the languages yeah so here you see
again in the top graph
the total amount of words
and then in the next one the new spanish
words and the new german words per month
yeah
and
at spanish we spanish at home we mostly
speak spanish as a
family language although it's a bit of a
mixed situation
but indeed apart from the neutral nouns
uh the kid was starting to first learn
more spanish words
right now or yeah at 26 months german
had caught up and um
and now it's actually more german words
and spanish words
but the other interesting
thing about that data said is that
we were in this pandemic context so the
linguistic context of the of the two
were very was very constant apart from
like few changes
and very finally we can see these
changes in in the patterns that we see
because you see the first graph so it's
very linear so the amount of new words
is more or less the same but you see the
speaks in the spanish and german words
the first change
happened when we changed the one who was
staying at home more with him uh and
there we see he was very quickly
learning spanish words and then the
german-speaking parents stayed at home
and this is slowed down it slews down a
bit
then
the grandparents came to visit bringing
more spanish
spanish content but even more being the
first people who didn't understand
german yeah so actually there he had to
make an effort to actually uh say german
words say spanish words and then we we
see this decrease in the in the number
of of german awards for that for that
month
then he started kindergarten and this
the german recovered
but then the grandparents visited again
so
uh there was another dip in
in the in the german and
well now that is is is pretty constant
with lots of german words uh and uh
spanish yeah being there had to say
and i thought this one was the most
interesting thing to look at
but then i got some ideas and i
took a look at the types of words
and for that i used spacey and spacey
has this
um property of a method of extracting
the
part of speech category of the word so
this is this tells you
is this word a noun
a proper noun
a verb adjective proposition
to be completely honest i tried this at
the beginning but at some point like my
linguistic knowledge was like what is
this word is this this is a preposition
this is like i don't know
so
i did it with spacey
and
yeah for each word you get
one one category
and things that might not be very
familiar are
or interjections so interjections are
these
words that can serve as complete
sentences like yes no or ah oh oops yeah
so all of these expressions are
interjections
um
and we have
at positions are actually prepositions
so family of propositions
and we have
yeah i think determiners so the
terminals are like articles uh or
particles that change um nouns
and what we see here
is that of course
it starts with proper nouns yeah names
uh
then with nouns
and then
what do you think comes next
verbs there are right always like
should be verbs
it's not verbs so adjectives adverbs
uh determinants
interjections
and then comes something strange and
weird from the german language that's
verb
particles so if you speak german if you
like close the door it's like
the particle is a two and what kids say
is they just say the particle so they
don't say to make but just
[Music]
and this has the effect that the verbs
come
very late yeah so almost one year after
starting talking the verbs start
appearing
uh
then the auxiliary verbs like uh
um
or something that like makes you like
build more complex sentences
particles like model particles like toch
or nua or things that
like more advanced speakers say
conjunctions which actually super
interesting because this is what
gives you the ability to make complex
sentences
prepositions finally and the last thing
to appear which is very funny is
articles they adidas yeah so
and so there is like no apparent content
there so actually it's just a
grammatical structure so it's really not
important if you put it in or if you say
it correctly it's also good news for all
of us non-german native speakers
who cannot nail them correctly all the
time
um and the last plot has actually the
amount of these new words
per type
um oops this animation is put
um
so
we do have the explosion of of nouns
the verbs come later but they start
catching up quickly same with adjectives
and adverbs
and all these other little words there
were there's just like a final infinite
amount of these words
propositions
conjunctions etc but once you have
so many
then you can build sentences yeah and
this was my mark of the kid actually
speaks in in full sentences
yes so
if you're ever in this pipeline looking
for some inspiration and and to get your
love back
for the data analysis skills i highly
recommend working on personal data
projects
and if you happen to come from other
fields
and just have coding skills personal
data projects are also a great way to
get inspired and come to us into the
data world
with this i finish here are my contacts
again
thanks for listening
a lot for your presentation paula it was
really entertaining
i really enjoyed it
um yeah we have a few questions on slido
uh the first question from lucia how do
you deal with privacy and consent when
using personal data friends related for
your projects in terms of data storage
processing etc
yeah that's a very good question and
that's also why i
don't use data from that's not are not
right now for for me or my family that
have the consent
and so far um all the data that i was
using was local
but i have been thinking and especially
in this this last project and talking
with my linguistic friends it was like
we have to make a nap out of this
because we we could enable um people to
give this but
around the thinking of
how to store your data how to enable
this uh this is what's
apart from time this is what keeps us
from actually doing that
so the solution i i don't i don't save
the data and i don't
take data from
nobody that's not in my immediate
field
um yeah thank you we have a second
question uh how did you collect your
child's words
yeah really it was in the phone i have
like a spreadsheet app
and the moment i noticed there was i was
like date
and
ward this was
really easy at the beginning but then
especially when he entered kindergarten
yeah then you lose a lot of contact time
uh with the kieran you have to be very
very very attentive
really riding and at some point i also
saw that there were lots of duplicates
and things missing of course because
once it gets it starts accelerating you
miss you miss
for sure words i've i've seen a ted talk
where um
a linguistic research was doing this
very professionally and he had
microphones and cameras in his in his
place
and then he was uh analyzing the data
i'm not
that professional so i was really just
with a with a simple spreadsheet
thank you other questions from lisa what
is your definition of a sentence where
did you draw the line between complex
clauses and sentences when saying the
kids start speaking in sentences yeah
well it is a very it's very it was a
very amateur definition of like
oh now i have the feeling that that are
sentences and uh for the complex clauses
it's when conjunctions actually appear
so but this is something i learned from
the researchers not my linguistic
knowledge yeah but that line of i have
the feeling now he speaks in sentences
it's really this mother feeling of like
oh wow so milestone arrived achieved
thank you other questions do you have a
strategy how to kill a prototype that
made it into production but was never
production ready
um so nothing is production nothing so
i think the farthest the thing come are
like things that i present at
conferences
but
yes so i i do have a
cemetery of notebooks on projects of
things that i don't use and there's no
strategy there
thanks a lot we still have questions for
one or two questions in the audience if
you have yeah i have a latest data
collection project
i just finished analyzing this so uh
there's there's there's no one there so
i i am thinking actually of making a
nice streamlit app out of the linguistic
uh linguistic data and
so this friend actually wants to start
like a like actually small project to
validate
linguistic like theoretical linguistic
research with empirical data
for um for language acquisition so i
guess this is what we will do what we'll
do next but yeah it's not in november
yet so ask me next year and
i might have come with new
ideas because i noticed the one
yes
no um so i don't plan this so much they
really they just like appear when out of
need
and i would like to to work on these
things more but of course there's just
so much time that you have so what do
you do you start collecting data and
whenever you have a deadline because you
need something or a talk then you just
really have to analyze it and make nice
plots yeah but i don't plan this
have you involved your partner
i tried right but like that's your thing
i want i want to see the insights but
it's this is your thing i do the board
game so it's yeah
yeah do you um plan on collecting
anymore about your child maybe
is he walking around right now
yeah
yes yes but no so he's yeah i think i
for now i finished
yeah i might have a last question are
you using your model to choose the next
board game or
um
that's a very good idea
[Laughter]
not yet
thanks a lot paula for this presentation